I love the smell of age of Ultron
trailers in the afternoon because that's
when I wake up because I'm a really lazy
bastard right we have another 1/3 age of
Ultron trailer ultimately I love the
first trailer I love this trailer the
second trailer
I liked enough but I feel like that is a
trailer we didn't need it was like
filler trailer with RL is just given
that trailer so the third trailer it's
actually going to kick ass it does kick
a lot of ice really cool [ __ ] in here
this trailer starts out Ultron in his
James Spader voice glories like I was
created to save the world
leave me Tony Stark's like I created
this guy to put a suit of armor around
the earth but the exact top has it
happened and black widows like yeah you
failed miserably
Ultron's like people look up at the sky
and they see hope I think I'll take that
from him first he rips out his ponytail
and by Pony telling me his digital head
charger I love this a man Ultron's on
his throne he's talking to Quicksilver
and Scarlet Witch is this y'all Tron I
know every Ultron stash or thing imagery
that I've seen not every but a lot of
them an iconic one shows Ultron sitting
on a throne looking badass you see him
like I told you I was gonna show you
something beautiful
isn't that chair beautiful not actually
a charity ROM and is there like this guy
is completely out of his [ __ ] hard
drive well there are some cool ass
scenes in this trailer that scene where
cap throws his shield it goes right into
Ultron shoulder and he rips it out and
throws it on the ground I saw once day
was like I look like Wolverine clauses
like way what's the Wolverine [ __ ] turns
out his Hawk eyes arrows but you know
they were like let's make it look like
Wolverine claws people got so excited
about spider-man let's give them
Wolverine ish just to get us excited
hands-down coolest action scene of the
trailer is when the Hulk is punching the
Hulkbuster up the building pieces reckon
of the million do-do-do-do-do reminded
me of Hulk ultimate destruction I was
like I remember that game it looked just
like that
that's line of the trailers when Tony
Stark's like there's no way we get
through this in cap in his Captain
America glory he's sitting there he's
like I got no plans tomorrow night
that's why you're awesome that's why
you're Captain America as well I'm in a
rout for you in Civil War the same er
Quicksilver uppercuts Captain America
when he's going full speed I think that
would detach his head like Johnny Cage
fatality soldiers oh god I think I just
killed Captain effector with an uppercut
and the last thing to like that the best
you got Ultron he's
flying there it's cool he's like I'm
flying he's like and all these Ultron
drones come out of nowhere you're like
you're all screwed they're like I'll
back-to-back just but it's like overhead
view it's all closing in you're like
that is gonna be awesome and then BOOM
age of Ultron title comes up you're like
that was cool oh but you gotta wait
until the very end the last shot shows
this dude's eyes just blah open up and
you're like holy [ __ ] that's vision yeah
that floating guy in the poster some
people have asked me like who the hell
is that that is vision folks straight
vision has arrived it's gonna be Jarvis
in this one I believe right that's what
I heard this information changes all the
time from what I understand Jarvis gets
a body in its vision my worry is that
these trailers are gonna show us too
much ultimately you look at this trailer
you're like I don't know anything I
didn't already know
we knew the premise when age of old
front was announced it was going to be
Ultron who gets created and he becomes
self-aware he's this big AI robot and he
tries to wipe out the Avengers and wipe
out the earth and in this trailer we
know that Ultron gets created and he
becomes self-aware he's this big AI
robot and he tries to wipe out the
Avengers and wipe out the earth and then
I can't say this trailer spoiler however
there's a lot of imagery I want to save
for the movie I'm like I'm really
cautious going into trailers I'm like
don't show me everything but when a
trailer like this ends and I just go
that's cool
can't help but talk about it alright
guys so the third Avengers age of Ultron
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about what was your favorite scene
in the trailer
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]